Hats Leesville common yeah skip not
before and ravinok around the below
shalt even their marks it's bahu missus
or and was war gerade Reggaeton tune
dermabrush Mahesh meet Laura lizard
jihad for a good 20 gr and heart
you will fight fusion and Political Independent on Tatas and rods noggins
offener Brief an Winkel Amerika oder sind an
Theresa May, als die wir
Ihnen danken würden, ja sehr,
Ravel, winziger Schrittmacher, sogar Mia, die auf dem
Spott dort gefunden wurde, wie ein Professor einmal
sagte, wenn Frauen die Macht
hätten, hätten sie die Dinge bereits in der Hand  geändert,
um an diesen Ort zu gelangen, würde ein kultureller Wandel erforderlich sein
, wenn Frauen oder 50 % der Führungskräfte
Frauen wären, 50 % der Fernsehmoderatoren, die
Dinge hätten sich bereits geändert, und
wäre es anders, ja, ich denke, es
wäre anders, wäre es
zu früh besser  um uns zu sagen Ho Chi Minh
sagte einmal über die Auswirkungen der Französischen
Revolution, es sei noch zu früh, um
dies zu sagen
Anders als Männer sind sie
vielleicht mitfühlender oder
fürsorglicher, aber sie werden sicherlich ein
anderes Verständnis
für Menschen haben, vor allem, weil Frauen, zumindest wenn
sie in heutigen Gesellschaften aufwachsen,
wirklich wissen müssen, wie die Machtgruppe ist
Die Machtgruppe funktioniert, muss nicht
wissen, wie die Machtgruppe funktioniert,
aber die Machtgruppe ohne Macht muss
die Machtgruppe kennen, damit sie dazu
neigen, dass Frauen dazu neigen,
viel aufmerksamer zu sein, könnte das Wort dafür
sein  verwendet werden könnten, wissen Sie, ich
spiele an der Frage herum, ob
es besser wäre, Sie wissen, es wäre
sicherlich anders
Wenn dir 50
% der Perspektive der Welt fehlen und
du dann diese 50% Perspektive hinzufügst, wie könnte es
nicht besser sein, wenn nur wo all das
Zeug discutir und Jesus zu ertragen es
interessierte mich zu Ohrlächeln C'  s hilft in
Ihrer Ehrlichkeit für die Garage, wenn er sich
bald für den internationalen Handel auf Redegeld verhärtet,
wenn Sie bis zum Datum
Ihres Goldman Sachs oder einer Boston
Consulting sehen, dass Goodwin
regiert und herzlich gut, dass Angst und
politisch orientiert ist, dass dieser Scanner alle unsichtbar macht
Sekretärin dieses Council of Women
World Leaders Bomb passiert Siesta na Hoga
Welle und fühle mich unter dem Fund, dass
es gut gehandhabt wird. Ich kann mich auch immer
fragen, ob ich es an die Spitze geschafft habe, aber
ich konnte hoffentlich einige
Änderungen vornehmen, um eine andere Perspektive einzubringen
Leute Eines der Dinge, die ich
am meisten mag, ist, wenn jemand auf mich zukommt, nachdem
ich vielleicht eine Rede gehalten habe, und sie sagen zu
mir, meine
Güte, so habe ich das noch nie gesehen,
besonders Männer, ich mag es, wenn
Männer auf mich zukommen und sagen, du weißt schon  Ich hatte nicht
wirklich darüber nachgedacht, wie du es ausdrückst
und dass ich das sehr mag
und ich denke, dass ich schon immer
Dinge ändern wollte, weißt du, einer von diesen
Leuten, zum Beispiel in der Wirtschaft
war sehr gut darin, Dinge zu ändern, um
zu sehen, was anders gemacht
werden musste, und als es dann geändert war, war es so, als wäre
es okay, ich bin fertig, ich werde
mit der nächsten Sache fortfahren, und einiges von dem, was Sie
tun, war meines Erachtens nur für ihn
erklärt, wenn wir in den Rückspiegel schauen
, weißt du im Leben, wie wir dahin gekommen sind
, wo wir jetzt sind,
dann gehst du zurück und du gehst, oh okay, was
war das für eine Entscheidung, meine Entscheidung zum
Beispiel, mich zu fragen, wie es
in den Vereinigten Staaten wäre, wenn  Wir hatten eine
Präsidentin, das war meine ursprüngliche Frage
vom Rat, und dann dachte
ich, vielleicht könnte ich jemanden treffen, der
Staatsoberhaupt oder Regierungschef war,
weil es in den Vereinigten Staaten leider noch niemanden gibt, dem
Sie diese Frage stellen können,
und dann ich  Ich fand heraus,
dass 15 Frauen lebten
, unter denen sie Präsidentin waren,
also dachte ich, okay, ich werde versuchen, eine
von ihnen zu treffen, die keine Ahnung hat, warum ich dachte, ich
könnte eine Präsidentin oder Premierministerin sein.
Ja, es ist in Ordnung, RTP 690 Carbon
CIT sicher  Universum in der Medizin
Karussells Esel Tofu in Lanham vs.
zehn höchsten Bolivien irgendein Präsident in
den neuesten Schiedsrichtern über Leinwand Fernsehen
spielt Major Zweiter oh ja ja keiner
interessanterweise keiner der Weltführer
, den ich um das Interview am 15. gebeten habe
keiner von ihnen hat mich umgedreht  Runter für ein
Interview Margaret Thatcher sagte, komm
zurück, nachdem du alle anderen getroffen hast, ja,
was ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass sie dachte, ich werde sie nie
wieder sehen.
Ich bin nicht Margit, das ist, was ich würde
sehr interessant, es ist nicht gerade die
Feministin in der Menge, aber sie war sehr
interessant, sehr neugierig, was ich als
Merkmal der Führung ansehe
Meine
Interviews wurden tatsächlich länger
und länger und länger, weil ich
ihnen erzählte, was die anderen gesagt hatten, es
war wirklich ziemlich faszinierend, das ist ein
anständiges Projekt des Weißen Hauses mit  Wenn wir sehen, dass
einige nicht anständige Frauenführer der
Welt kokonieren, lässt es den Hai
Sie meiden, Percy, technisch gesehen, sind sie
intimer ethnischer Anführer in Transienten,
und sie CFR, die auch wir die Couch in
GC-Duschen bieten, bieten wir thailändischen Fans
über einem Special an  Abendessen und ist nicht gut,
Sie wissen, dass es ein sehr privater Rat ist, wie
Sie sich vorstellen können, weil er sowohl
amtierende Staats- und Regierungschefs
als auch ehemalige Staats- und Regierungschefs
hat, deshalb gibt es 74, weil es
nicht wirklich 74 Stadtführer gibt, es gibt
normalerweise nicht mehr als  10 12 14 zu jeder
Zeit, die tatsächlich Staatsoberhäupter sind,
also ist es sehr privat, auf viele Arten
arbeiten wir mit anderen Organisationen zusammen, wir machen
Dinge während der UN-Treffen, wir machen
Dinge mit einigen der anderen anderen
Organisationen, aber wenn sie zusammenkommen, ist
es interessant  Sie sprechen über ihre
eigenen Erfahrungen und
interessanterweise sprechen
die neuen Staatsoberhäupter 20 nach dem Rat
immer noch über die gleiche Sache,
ja, über eine geprüfte Stimme  Haare kleiden
dasselbe, die Pressemedien, von denen Sie wissen, dass sie
nicht so viele Fehler machen können wie Männer,
Sie wissen, dass es nur ein anderer
Standard ist
Neue heilige Investition uns Farm es ist
zumindest ein paar Mal positiv Mann im
Babyladen - also Wissenschaftlerin Mira Mädchen benehmen sich
gut. Ich meine, Sie fädeln viel mehr
Nadeln ein. Sie wissen, dass es das ganze Problem ist,
und Sheryl Sandberg bringt es zur Sprache, Sie
kennen Sie  Kannst du nicht zu viele
Fehler machen
, weißt du, weil die Leute weggehen, sieh, du
weißt, dass Frauen Fehler machen, jetzt können Männer
doppelt so viele Fehler machen, und die Leute
bemerken es nicht so sehr, also
kannst du nicht so etwas sein  durchsetzungsfähig
du weißt, weil dann die Leute sagen, du bist
aggressiv Leute wollen, dass du
gemocht werden musst weißt du, aber manchmal ist es schwer
gemocht zu werden und durchsetzungsfähig zu sein du weißt, dass
du dich behaupten kannst du weißt, was
du sagst, woran du glaubst du weißt und  Männer
tun  Sie müssen nicht sowohl gemocht als auch
selbstbewusst sein, sie können Leute sein, die sie nicht
mögen, aber sie mögen, wie sie als
Anführer sind, also ist es für Frauen oft eine wirklich harte Bindung.
Jesus heißt Jonathan
DC. Ich habe herausgefunden, was passiert und so
weiter  Ist das nicht strittig und schwache
Anfänge relevant zu werden, ist nicht V - ding gut
Manchmal schaut man sich nur den Widerstand an, von dem
man sagt, dass man weiß, dass das
Beste, was man tun kann, nicht an
etwas Interessanteres denken kann, als das, wenn
man es hätte  Wenn
du also ein bisschen Sinn für Humor und
ein bisschen Abstand dazu haben kannst,
sagst du: Ja, du weißt, komm schon, du kannst
klüger sein, wenn du mich angreifen
willst, weißt du so etwas  und Sie
entwickeln ein Vertrauen in das, worüber
Sie sprechen. Sie kennen nur die
Erfahrungen, die Sie gemacht haben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Frauen an Selbstvertrauen
mangelt  Ein
Verständnis, dass, wenn sie Sie kennen
, zum Chef gehen und sagen, geben Sie mir jetzt eine Gehaltserhöhung
t  Der Boss vor ho,
bist du nicht ein bisschen aggressiv, du weißt,
wo du als Mann hingehen musst, gib mir jetzt eine Gehaltserhöhung,
weil ich es verdiene, ja, natürlich ist es
ja, weißt du, ich meine, ich scherze oft, dass
du weißt, dass selbstbewusste Männer solche kleinen
Länder erobern  der Frauen haben um eine Beförderung gebeten,
also sind es diese
Kaufleute und die meisten weiblichen Führungskräfte
, mit denen ich gearbeitet und die ich
kennengelernt habe, sie haben herausgefunden, wie man sich
durch diese kleinen Landminen schlängelt,
und sie müssen manchmal durchgehen,
denken sie  sie haben herausgefunden, dass sie
wissen, wie man Humor verwendet,
was meiner Meinung nach oft sehr hilft
haben es herausgefunden, aber für
junge Frauen ist es anfangs ziemlich schwierig
, es herauszufinden, weil sie
in der Schule sind, wenn sie in der Schule sind, sind
fünfzig Prozent Mädchen und Frauen, junge
Frauen in der Schule, Männer, die sie
nicht sind  Sport sie sind nicht
daran gewöhnt dann sie  gehen raus in die
Arbeitswelt und sie sagen, oh mein Gott, du weißt, dass die
Dinge anders sind, weißt du, und ich
werde uns ihren Trost so in der Nähe von zu Hause anbieten,
damit ich sehen kann, dass ich sehen kann, wie
ein Kunde aushält und im Grunde
alles fertigstellt, Farhad, ja, ich  Ich habe das zweimal gemacht
Ich bin ziemlich aus meiner Komfortzone herausgekommen Ich habe das
erste Fahrrad de birria, was ich nicht
vorschlage, dass du es tust Ich habe es eigentlich für dich getan,
also kannst du mir danken, das war neunzehn,
ja, es war, bevor ich die Führer getroffen habe,
weil  Es war 1994, das
mir den Mut gab, die Führer zu treffen, und
dann radelte ich über die Seidenstraße,
ja, das war noch interessanter
und schwieriger, aber
ich wollte aus meiner Komfortzone herauskommen, von der ich einen
anderen Teil sehen wollte  Die Welt, die du kennst, ich
empfehle dir nicht, es zu tun.
Hanukkahs Karamellglück und Vashti
beneidet, und wie republikanisch du
redest, ich kann es nicht gut sagen, wenn
davon ausgegangen wird, dass lange Tore und mittlere Herzen aufeinanderprallen
im weißen i kann man sich nicht politisch fühlen  Da der
Vino mit dem sowjetischen Viton in
Richtung Minuten für Monster kollidiert
, haben wir noch einen ziemlich langen Weg vor
uns. Es war interessant, sich die Statistiken anzusehen,
insbesondere die Statistiken des
Weltwirtschaftsforums zu Geschlechterunterschieden.
Ja,
wir berichten, es war interessant was  Sie haben
gesehen, dass auf der ganzen Welt die Gesundheitslücken
so ziemlich nicht in jedem
Land, aber in den meisten Ländern die Lücken
zwischen Jungen und Mädchen und Männern und Frauen
in Bezug auf die Geldbeträge geschlossen haben,
die für Männer und Frauen ausgegeben werden. Diese Lücke
ist ziemlich  Geschlossen Die Bildungslücke ist
ziemlich geschlossen In vielen Ländern machen
Frauen zum
Beispiel mehr Hochschulabschlüsse als Männer, so dass die Lücke
geschlossen wird, aber was nicht geschlossen wird, sind die
wirtschaftlichen Anwendungen und die politischen Lücken,
und ich denke, viele von uns hatten diese Überzeugung
philosophischer Glaube, der ihn
wieder gesund macht, ich werde gebildet und dann
kommen sie natürlich in die Arbeitswelt,
natürlich werden sie da oben
, in die politische Welt und  dann
, dass diese Gleichstellung gut passieren würde,
verzögert das Forum die Anzahl der Jahre, die
es dauern wird, bis zur Gleichstellung an diesem
Punkt. Ich denke, sie sind bei 217 Jahren und
das ist länger als im letzten Jahr,
also ist das so lange, wie ich es besitze  die anderen
ja ja ja jetzt sind einige Länder
näher dran als andere Länder, diese Typen zu schließen,
die Salz für Hungrige geben, und
außerdem ist es Skandinavier, ein medizinischer
NEBOSH, Brite, der den Osten geschlagen hat, lange, als
Norvik der erste Mann war, der nicht auf denen war, wissen Sie,
wir alle, wir alle untersuchen  Das nenne ich
das nordische Nirvana. Was tun sie
und warum tun sie das? Sie wissen, einige
Forscher
und Emissionen werden ein paar Dinge sagen.
Eine relativ kleine homogene
Gesellschaft. Die Gewerkschaften waren also schon
immer ein sehr mächtiger Teil der nordischen
Länder  Dieses Gefühl der Gleichberechtigung
ist in einigen dieser Länder in den Gewerkschaften
verankert, interessanterweise in
den Fischereiländern ihres Fischereilandes.
Was bedeutet das
also?  Die Männer gingen
elf Monate im Jahr zum Fischen, und die Frauen
blieben zu Hause und taten alles,
um die Parlamente rund um
die Wirtschaft zu erzürnen, Sie taten persönlich
alles und kamen dann zurück, und dann
gingen sie wieder hinaus, damit Sie es wissen
es ist und jetzt sehen wir uns Tausende
von Jahren Kultur an, ja, diese Sache,
jetzt sind sie nicht perfekt, aber
Sie kennen sie sicherlich besser als die meisten, und
anscheinend wissen Sie, dass sie
den Wert dieser Gleichberechtigung verstehen, Junior
Manomohan und so ziemlich alle  von ihnen,
mit einigen kleinen Ausnahmen, verwenden einige
eine Menge positiver Mechanismen, die Sie wissen,
Schaden in ihrem Parlament, zum Beispiel
einige von ihnen sollten zuerst ihre
Kabinette zu 50 Prozent aus Frauen und zu
50 Prozent aus Männern im Kabinett haben, einige
von ihnen haben sowohl den Präsidenten als auch  Der
Premierminister, also mag ich die
Vereinigten Staaten nicht, die eine einzige Position haben,
was bedeutet, dass das Staatsoberhaupt,
das eher zeremoniell ist,
oft eine Frau im Kopf ist  f
Regierung, die mehr Exekutive ist,
wäre der Mann, aber dann fingen die Leute an
, sich mit Frauen als Führungspersönlichkeiten vertraut zu machen
, wissen Sie, und deshalb denke ich, dass es einige
wirklich interessante Dinge gibt, die wir
von der Sitzung in den nordischen Ländern über
Croissants als Geschäftsberuf lernen können, wenn
sie ihre Pizza beschmutzen  In East London ist der Bosch-
Käfer also eine Freikarte. Es ist der
Präsident in Island. Er gibt Bier und
schwatzt, um zu nommen. Hören Sie. Sie fühlen sich
beide.
t als
unsigned ablehnen freundlicher diese Garnierung
pflegen unquote
seinen Osten nicht Monat unter Arten
gut er kommt aus tut Jnanis gut
ja, wie würden Sie wissen, Jesse, das war
seine Geschichte, die sie erzählt, dass sie
Männer gewesen und völlig im Amt war
sechzehn Jahre,
also die am längsten sitzende
Präsidentin der Welt, aber sie sagte, sie
würde in Island herumreisen, sie sei
seit acht Jahren im Amt und rede mit den
Kindern  Dann entdeckte sie,
dass die Kinder unter 8 Jahren alle
fragen mussten, ob nur eine Frau
Präsidentin sein kann, und der Junge sagte, er solle sagen, ich
kann nicht Präsidentin sein, weil ich nur
eine Frau als Präsidentin sehe
wirklich die Macht, die Sie kennen, das ist die
Macht des Symbols, das ist die Macht,
Frauen in den Medien, das ist die
Macht von Ihnen, kennen Sie das Vorbild, ich meine
, es ist eine wirklich starke, starke Macht,
und jetzt wissen Sie, dass sie sie
hatten  Als Präsident haben sie jetzt eine
Premierministerin, ja, also alle vier Rechnungen
iranischer Ausdruck, da die UN
glavish Fischstäbchen int
wollen, in Schweden kollidieren hölzerne
feministische Probleme, die sich aus einer Anika-Verletzung manifestieren,
sprechen Chi Minh und auf
Goatse Adichie, wir sollten alle
Feministinnen sein, resultierend aus Olivares Design  also
das steckt hinter der unterstützung analyse teenager
jahr wiegand fatale in ständig lund
ihr schweiß war umgekehrt ich denke bob
kurze antwort nein aber zum glück weißt du
warum nicht ich meine was sie da drin
sagt ist so  real und so mächtig
, dass Sie wissen, dass wir alle Feministinnen sein sollten, da
unser Titel sowohl Männer als auch Frauen
verdienen, dass sie vollständig menschlich sein müssen, wissen Sie
, und dass Männer, die Sie kennen,
Hypothesen aufstellt und sagt, dass Sie wissen, dass
Männer in einigen Käfigen ihrer Rollen sind  Genauso
wie Frauen in ihren Rollen in Käfigen sitzen,
denke ich, gibt es bei Männern ein wachsendes
Verständnis dafür, dass man weiß, wenn
man hart sein muss und muss, darf man nicht weinen
und man muss wissen, dass man immer an
der Spitze sein und Konkurrenten sein muss, aber das  Sie
wissen, dass dies Ihre
Fähigkeit, Emotionen zu zeigen,
verschiedene Dinge zu fühlen, schrumpft, Sie wissen, also weiß
ich, dass ich völlig damit einverstanden bin, dass
die Käfige, in die Frauen gesteckt werden, Sie wissen
, dass sie nett sein müssen, Sie wissen, dass sie es
müssen  Seien Sie besorgt, ob sie verheiratet sind,
sie müssen sich Sorgen um Männer machen, Sie
wissen, dass Männer nicht so besorgt um Frauen sind
, aber ich glaube, ich glaube,
sie hat Recht, dass es
auch Käfige für Männer gibt, denn warum sollten Sie das
annehmen?  Menschen t  Hut Männer hätten
nicht die volle Bandbreite an Emotionen
, die Frauen haben, aber die Gesellschaft sagt nein
, weine nicht
du weißt, dass du wütend sein kannst, aber du kannst es nicht
wirklich sein du weißt, du kannst
deine anderen Gefühle jetzt nicht wirklich für Frauen zeigen  Sie
können nicht so oft wütend sein Imperioli sicher,
dass es genau so bedrohlich heiß auf uns
ist
.  Darren ist
zwischen Geschlecht und Geschlecht rechte Geschlechter von
denen, aber biologische Unterschiede und es war
wahrscheinlich vor achtzigtausend
Jahren nützlich oder was auch immer ich mir diese
Zahl ausdenke, als Männer Bisons auf den Kopf schlagen mussten,
wissen Sie, um gut zu überleben, haben wir
keine  Zu viele Bisons laufen
nicht mehr herum,
ja, es ist, dass sich diese besonderen Fähigkeiten
zu unterschiedlichen Bedürfnissen entwickelt haben,
und ich denke, Sie wissen,
dass wir die Einschränkungen untersuchen müssen, die jedes
Geschlecht an diesem Punkt hat, also sicher, dass
es einige sexuelle Determinanten gibt
Wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad durch Sibirien
fahre, waren die Männer ziemlich gut darin, die
Hügel hinaufzufahren, weil sie
auch mit dem Gewicht gekämpft hatten. Ich war viel
besser in der Ebene. Ich kann einfach
ewig in der Ebene fahren
wirklich so weit, aber als
es auf den Hügeln anfing, wer dort hingeht, geht
es einfach richtig, okay, gut, ja,
es ist nur eine andere Physiologie
Der König
über jemanden, der über das
andere Zeug gesprochen hat, ist das Geschlechterkonstrukt. Sie wissen,
wie Sie sollten,
wenn Sie wissen, wie wir
Sie messen werden, wissen Sie so etwas, und
dann legen Sie darüber, was wir sagen,
was eine gute Führungskraft ausmacht
Nun, du bist durchsetzungsfähig Du weißt, du musst
groß sein
Du musst nur wissen Komm rein
und sei der einsame Cowboy, der in
den Sonnenuntergang reitet und ein Finger König Arthur
Du ziehst das Schwert aus dem
Stein in der heutigen Welt ist es wahrscheinlich
sollte Sie wahrscheinlich nicht sehr weit bringen und
wird Sie nicht sehr weit bringen.
Ja, alle diese sind Stereo, um zu gefallen,
es würde nicht 14 auf Saiten
im System verstärken, das ich brauche, um ein Haus für
den Raum zu hosten, wenn einige zusammenstoßen sie don  't get
gerechtigkeit eigentlich zweite paar verhalten
das sind reparierte drachen Forester lange
passiert es ist ein junger stil amerikanische
schiffe wenn du öffnest du weißt bekommt schauspieler
gesundheit shaytans symbol du kannst
die hardware sehen also ist es endlich der kongress
gut die hilfeseite verstößt gegen november
das ist  auf akustischen Gitarren, wenn sie
das Gefühl machen, ein Vereiniger, sagen Sie es und
nach dem berühmten gemeinen Klima, indígenas,
Trauma, kein weiches Nein, oh, ich meine, es ist,
wenn das so weitergehen kann, es ist definitiv ein
Weg in die richtige Richtung.
Ich meine, es ist mehr so, wie Amerika
wie Sie aussieht  Kennen Sie dieses Maß an Vielfalt,
und ich denke, Sie wissen natürlich, dass
es eine riesige Energie gab, eine riesige Energie
im Gegensatz zur derzeitigen
Regierung, Sie wissen, wie
Frauen behandelt werden und wie wir vorgehen wollen,
und Sie kennen viele Frauen  sagte
okay genug,
wir sind fertig, als Isis erkannte mr.  Donald
Trump Duncan ist sein Ich [ __ ] wie ein Wächter-
Esel, weißt du nicht, ich werde
nicht dankbar sein, ein bisschen zu weit
zu gehen, aber hat er gezeigt, dass ich denke, was er
philosophisch gezeigt hat, ist, dass der
technologische Wandel richtig ist
Fortschritt der Technologie und
Fortschritt der Innovation, das ist sicher,
es geht immer weiter, die
Zeit für eine neue Generation von Geräten und die
Dinge werden immer kürzer, also ist die
Technologie sicher, was nicht sicher
ist, ist kultureller Fortschritt und kultureller Wandel, den
wir denken, oh, Technologie wird es immer
geben  Verbessern Sie sich,
deshalb sollte sich die Kultur immer verbessern.
Sie können ins Mittelalter zurückgehen.
Sie wissen, dass die Taliban ins
Mittelalter zurückgekehrt sind. Haben sie nicht
moderne Technologie in diesem Prozess verwendet
?
Sie wissen, dass es eine
Reversion zurück war, und für viele Frauen
waren sie viel
zu weit fortgeschritten, um zu dieser Art von
archetypischer Person zurückzukehren, die Sie kennen, die Frauen verspottet hat
, die vielleicht sind  Du wirst auch Männer töten,
aber du weißt, wer es auf eine
bestimmte Art und Weise bei Frauen macht, also wurden Frauen
wütend und du weißt, dass sie
besonders afroamerikanische Frauen
reindrängen, sie haben sie wirklich wirklich getreten, und es ist
wichtig, dass du nicht mehr gegangen sein kannst  Frauen
in der Politik, es sei denn, mehr Frauen in der
Politik kandidieren für ein Amt, und
es war wunderbar, all
diese Frauen kandidieren zu sehen, und es gibt auch einen
kleinen Grund dafür,
dass ich weiß nicht, wie viele Jahre ich noch
muss  Denken Sie, dass Frauen in der Lage waren, vollständig
beim Militär zu sein,
ja, und Frauen haben nicht den
sogenannten Titel sieben, die Vereinigten
Staaten konnten vollständig im Sport sein,
ja, und das hat einen ganzen Kader
von Frauen entwickelt, die
Führungspositionen hatten, ja und so  Wenn Sie sich ansehen,
wer kandidiert hat, werden Sie sehen, dass viele, viele
Veteranen für ein Amt kandidierten, weil sie
Führungsqualitäten im
Militär entwickeln und
keinen Unsinn darüber machen werden, dass sie für ein
Amt kandidieren, von dem Sie wissen, dass sie es bekommen haben  Dieselbe Art
von Überprüfung und sie bekommen
immer noch solche Sachen, aber es ist so,
dass vieles davon nur die absolute Zahl sagt,
jetzt sind wir immer noch weit hinter Ihnen,
wissen Sie, wir rangieren im Gender
Gap Report immer noch bei etwas 70 und wir  Wir
fallen immer weiter zurück, weil die meisten
Länder positive Mechanismen haben
und wir ja nicht, also werden wir
weiterhin hinter die Fischrechte zurückfallen, die
dieser angeborenen ja auch HD-Nation schuldig sind
Dies im Flashdance-
Index von Nathans 116 Plots,
wenn angenommen wird, dass eine Klasse und ein
Jahrzehnt als Phänomene der Francois
Abidin FF-Schule diese Hoo-ha-Position oder
eine Erkenntnis und die [ __ ] auf das Positive
in Ratsangelegenheiten annehmen, wenn eine Klasse und ein
Jahrzehnt streiten  Die Scindia ist ziemlich auf die
Herabstufung und der Kommentar ist eine Glasur
und ein Jahrzehnt. Lassen Sie mich diese Frage gut
zuerst. Ich muss Ihnen sagen, ich glaube nicht, dass
es eine Glasdecke gibt. Okay,
ich denke nur, es ist eine dicke Schicht von Ma  n das ist es
also, was Sie durchbrechen,
bringen Sie das Glas zum Klingen, für eine ungefähr dicke
Schicht, ja, es ist eine Herausforderung
Eine Reihe der Frauen
, die Präsidentinnen waren, heißt
Rat. Ja, das sind genau unsere
Mitglieder unseres Rates, weil sie
Präsidentinnen waren, wissen Sie, also
scheint das Rotationssystem zu funktionieren. Ich weiß nicht,
wie viel Macht das anzeigt, aber  Es ist eine
Position, die VHF zu
haben, die kein Engländer ist,
also ist es ein in der Politikelite unser Gelübde
in der VHF Xena Zwiebeln Rüben und
positiver Eamonn von Wien Schlüssel, wie Nancy
Verkäufe im VHF-Karbid ablaufen
dass Englisch ops genau durch das Posten einer
Beratung und Intimität und ich
sage immer wieder matschige Tricks oder ein Englisch ein Spiel, das
Sie beenden können und nicht auslassen können
, entzündet sich, ja, Sie wissen, ich denke,
wir suchen alle nach dem Trick  Eine
Sache, die die Glühbirne einschalten wird,
scheint niemand gefunden zu haben, aber
es gibt viele Dinge, von denen die Leute jetzt
wissen, dass sie funktionieren. Ich meine, die Schweiz ist
in vielerlei Hinsicht ein konservatives Land,
und ein Großteil der Schweizer Wirtschaft basiert auf
Finanzinstituten, die in  und von
sich aus sehr konservativ sind, ja,
Sie haben eine Industrie, die
konservativ sein kann oder auch nicht, aber ich denke, dass
zum Beispiel ich keine Quelle kenne, von der Sie
mir sagen können,
dass sie Quoten für Vorstandssitze hat.
Ja, ich war noch nicht fertig, weil es ist  Nur
ein bisschen Deskriptor, aber diesen Aufstieg im Parlament überleben,
Vaterseite, das Herz etwas belasten, mm-hmm, ja, es ist
nichts,
ja, ja
Brett wie in
Norwegen und zum Beispiel mit seinen vierzig
Prozent nicht zu sehen, ob wir auf gleicher Höhe mit
Norwegern sind, wissen Sie, mm-hmm ja ja nein,
da ist das längste ja von ihnen und
was interessant ist  Sie haben festgestellt, dass sich
bei dieser kritischen Masse von Frauen in den
Vorständen die Governance-Prozesse
ändern. Sie haben zum Beispiel festgestellt, dass Frauen
die Vorstandsmaterialien lesen, aber was sie herausgefunden
haben, ist, dass jetzt die Männer
zum Vorstand kommen und den Vorstand gelesen haben
Materialien, so dass die bloße Anwesenheit von
Frauen das Verhalten der Männer verändert, was ich
immer mag. Sie wissen, dass es ein
Denkprozessspiel ist
, wenn es Santa
Affectiva ist. Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass gemischte
Teams die besten sind, die Sie kennen, weil zum
Beispiel in dieser Studie  Über Norwegen stellten
sie fest, dass Männer dazu neigen,
die kurzfristigen Auswirkungen von Vorstandsentscheidungen zu betrachten.
Frauen tendieren dazu,
die langfristigen Auswirkungen von Vorstandsentscheidungen zu
betrachten
Männer neigen dazu, die Auswirkungen von Entscheidungen auf die Aktionäre zu betrachten. Frauen neigen dazu, die
Auswirkungen von Entscheidungen
auf die Interessengruppen zu
betrachten  Ich bin eine große
Befürworterin der Art des Mixes, balanciere die
Herausforderungen aus, wenn wir sagen, Balance
Fifty-Fifty. Es ist in vielerlei Hinsicht wirklich interessant. Es
gibt eine großartige Forscherin
namens Geena Davis, die zum
Beispiel herausgefunden hat, dass Männer 50 Prozent sehen, wenn Frauen 20 % eines
Raums ausmachen  und wenn Frauen
zu 30 Prozent im Raum sind, sehen Männer 60
Prozent, also eine Mehrheit, obwohl
sie keine Mehrheit sind, also wissen Sie, wir
schauen auf das Teleskop, ja, Stephen
Shappell hat sogar entwickelt und uns DC für
char str2 PCM
mm-hmm Monsun  Ja, es ist mein Kindermädchen und
Razak ist nicht einfach. Der Wunsch der Webstuhlklasse
impliziert, dass ich ein Monopolstück von
20% verdiene, weil ich nicht fremden Essig habe,
den alle lieben - weiß alles,
was Bohan uns durchgesickert ist und
uns mit durchgesickerten Daten versorgt, die ich unter gefunden habe  der
kindle als gegeben sind sie gerade
im kindergarten zu finden : panzer
der die dk schnell und einfach gefunden hat und
außerhalb li muslin auf so vitae die
obersten jungs ja von miele drehen weiter
zimmer und schossen foul und weiter seinen staub
vi  llage Johnson strahlt den König
aus, es ist nicht das Entscheidende,
denn wenn Sie diese Forschung
über Lohnunterschiede und geschlechtsspezifische Lohnunterschiede lesen,
versuchen sie im Grunde,
die Positionen, die Frauen in der Kinderbetreuungsverantwortung einnehmen, stabil zu
halten, wenn sie all das innehaben  Sie wissen, dass
es immer noch eine Lücke zwischen Männern gibt, und
wir sind jetzt ein Teil davon, dass Frauen
dafür bestraft werden, dass sie mehr Geld verlangen als
Männer, aber Sie wissen, dass die
Briten wirklich etwas haben,
jetzt, wo sie es sind.  Um diese
Gehaltsunterschiede transparent zu machen, müssen sie einen
Bericht erstellen, der an die Öffentlichkeit geht. Ich
denke, Sie wissen, dass die Schweiz gut daran tun würde
, hinter uns zu investieren.
Nun, es ist in gewisser Weise peinlich genug für Unternehmen, dann wird ihnen die andere Sache
als potenzielle politische
Haftung für die
Zahlung ausgesetzt  Menschen unterschiedlich, also denke ich,
ja, jetzt haben einige Länder wie
Schweden gute Arbeit geleistet, um sicherzustellen, dass
Mutterschaftsurlaub und Vaterschaftsurlaub
gleich sind und erforderlich sind, nein ja und  Ich denke
, das ist auch sehr gut, weil ansonsten
die Frauen, die du kennst, einen
unverhältnismäßigen Teil der Kinderbetreuung übernehmen, sie geben den
Männern Zeit, um erfolgreich zu sein, und sie subventionieren
Männer, hmm, weißt du, aber wenn es 50/50 wäre, weißt du
, und dann gibt es kein Stigma, weil
oft  Es gibt ein Stigma für Frauen,
die Kinder haben, ja, oh, sie ist nicht
verpflichtet oder was auch immer,
was überhaupt nicht wahr ist, aber ich und ich
denke, es ist gut für Männer, bei
der Erziehung der Kinder zu helfen, ein Teil davon zu sein, ein Partner zu sein und
diese Windeln zu wechseln  Wir sind nicht für
sie als Hobbykumpel gefährdet, für die
ich dieses Feld übersprungen habe. Das Überspringen ist
Rechte von Brunnen zum Teilen.
t besonders Prabhu
Dysfunktion Leandro Medici Glasur und ein
Jahrzehnt Leben zum Ausdruck kommen auf die neue
Sendung schöne amerikanische Nation Orca
stehen auf der Genesis treffen ein weiteres Haus
weit das American Orchestra in s  ip
zigarre garn spiel adam ist fertig
interesante und parker auch orchester
schaden das musical und musical in
refraktsyndrom für hände da sein in einem
hinterland zur durchsetzung besessen
bis jetzt ist ein interesse und besonders nachdem
er mir etwas leidenschaft in den klang
besonders abscheulich weil und gezeigt hat  Wenn du
es wieder getan hättest, hättest du zehn insgesamt zehn in
einer Art Tode Seite Kadar Thomas
Pakusas für hängende Ökologie eingeladen Cena
dazu eingeladen, diese Wahlkommission
mehr von der Musik zu verlassen Kurt tut das nicht in
der Ecke Mission auf Lichter und der
Kerl klettern  und Vilya gehen zur Musik, die
berüchtigte alte Altamira und erlöst den
unschuldigen Klarman Billy, den ehrlichen
Iman, eine unsterile Geige und schreibt, ihre
Mutter ist so matschig auf DX plus 74, das Aufhängen wird
aufgeregt, es ist eine staubige Schlägerei auf jedem
Charakterständer, der hineingeworfen wird, und es ist
geöffnet, um auf die für zu kommen  Tierärzte häufig auf
fertig krank anwesend Ich verletzte es ist ein
hängender harter
Reuter T sie antworten das Stirnrunzeln ihrer
bis-- die Firma von Behinderungen ist
das ganze Braun es  ist keine Frage von
Phil Prozent Unsinn es ist krank über die
schnelle hier nehmen Moderator es ja
talentlos war Standard Wirtschaft sterben
Viet sagte und Frauen die Signia Ende und
Währung wurde gemartert auf unsere
Vereinbarung Auftrag ein Name
MZ kommt nicht bei Familien trifft Blimp zur
Verfügung  auf sriracha einer mission,
diese abzufangen, indem wir für
tyler als einsatzgruppe sorgen, ist kein husten, der kleinste
wir schulden ihm keinen start in das skript,
ah, das ist kein zoo
hoondi tagging, an das ich nicht glaube  Faultier auf der
einen Seite bei der NAM macht Manis in einer
Affäre wie Howard oder die Höhe im
Streit knapp Optus hauptsächlich Art. Ich
wünsche Ihnen Glück Team Pacht 2011
Transaktionspartei Wolga Deutsche oda stellen
sich aggressiv vor, eine Sorte insgesamt
Wunden im polnischen Vas Madman-Verfall
derzeit zu halten  meine Würde Stereoröhre
vor gut du weißt es ist interessant
weil Ohren wen ich gut kenne du weißt sie
sie sie tatsächlich abkürzen ein
bisschen sicher sie musste aber sie haben
das entdeckt wenn es kein
Auto gab  Als sie hinter dem Bildschirm auf den Boden streichelten,
mussten die Frauen ihre Schuhe ausziehen,
und dann ging ein Mann in Schuhen
neben ihr her, also war die Annahme, dass
alle Männer in Ordnung waren, ja, also jedes
interessante Detail, also wusste jeder, dass Sie einen
subtilen Vorteil hatten, den niemand hatte  subtile
Benachteiligung, denn wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass
Frauen benachteiligt werden, vergessen wir,
dass manche Männer oft
einen
subtilen Vorteil erhalten  sagt,
dass Sie wissen, dass ich an die Spitze gekommen bin, weil
es eine Meritokratie war und nur die
Besten es schaffen usw. und dann zeigt Iris-Beispiel
, dass Sie wissen, dass ich das jetzt auch erweitern
werde, nur weil es insofern interessant ist,
dass die Zahl der nicht-weißen Nicht-
Europäer geht  up in Symphony
Orchestra's mm-hmm
warum, weil die Annahme ist, dass Sie wissen, dass
ich Ihnen das perfekte Beispiel geben werde,
wie der chinesische Oboist Brahms
Bach Beethoven interpretieren kann, müssen Sie sicherlich ein
Weißer sein  Europäer, Sie wissen, sie mochten
ja Deutsch und Deutsch nicht weniger,
und ich benutze das absichtlich, weil der
beste Oboist der Welt Lin Wang ist,
ein Chinese, der der erste Vorsitzende von
Williston bei den New York Philharmonic ist,
aber bis heute fragen Reporter ihn immer noch,
wie können Sie  interpretieren Sie Brahms, Sie sind
Chinese, ja, also macht der Bildschirm das
Gleiche, und jetzt wurde der Bildschirm ursprünglich
gestartet, denn wenn Sie ein
Lehrer für einen Schüler waren, ja, und
Sie einer der Richter der Schüler waren
, wollten sie nicht, dass Sie einen Vorteil verschaffen
Ihr Schüler hat
ursprünglich so mit dem Bildschirm begonnen, aber dann haben sie
entdeckt, dass dies ging und die Tatsache, dass
Frauen es haben, also wissen Sie, dass ich es mag
, weil es zeigt, wenn Sie
all diese Bewusstlosigkeit wegnehmen, die Sie kennen,
dann fangen Sie an, das Wahre zu sehen  Fähigkeiten
und Leistung, also ja, Sie haben Recht,
viele Organisationen versuchen
, einige dieser Art von
Blindinterviews und all diese Art von Zeug herauszufinden,
es ist immer noch schwierig, weil das höhere y
Man kommt in eine Organisation, je subtiler
sie ist, und das wissen Sie, weil die meisten
Unternehmen, wahrscheinlich in der Schweiz,
auch kein Aufnahmeproblem haben, wenn
sie am unteren Ende der
Organisation ankommen. Ja, ziemlich gute
Balance, wenn sie kein Upgrade-Programm haben  nach
dir ja ja und das ist das problem
das ist das problem es ist so ein
verschwörungsplan buch und sie sind von
sheryl sandberg chefin telefon von facebook 20 direkt in einem sie lehnte sich vor und sah rum und versuchte sich an ein bestimmtes image einer spießigen einstimmung zu halten
Distanz ist ADIZ, es ist nicht du weißt ich
denke sie ich denke in vielerlei Hinsicht hat sie
den Leuten die Augen geöffnet sie brachte eine
Menge Forschung in das in das
Buch Sie sprechen über einige dieser
Forschungen Ich denke, sie hat dazu beigetragen,
die Vorstellung zu verstärken, dass  Sie wissen, dass Frauen das nicht können, wenn
sie durchsetzungsfähig sein wollen
, müssen sie gemocht werden. Diese Art von Entscheidungen, über die
wir gesprochen
haben  Aus der
Perspektive einer
ganz ehrlich weißen wohlhabenden Frau und
es gibt eine Menge Frauen, die nicht weiß und
wohlhabend sind, wissen Sie, wir kämpfen nur damit
, über die Runden zu kommen und wollen nur
Lohngerechtigkeit und solche Dinge,
und vieles davon war ich zu unterscheiden
zwischen dem, was ich den Samen im Boden nenne,
der Samen ist das Individuum, was
muss das Individuum tun, um sich
selbst voranzubringen, aber der Boden ist die
Institution, wissen Sie, was die
Institution tut, um Menschen voranzubringen, also
wissen Sie, dass das perfekte Beispiel für mich ist, wissen Sie
Meine Vorstellung von der lautesten Ente,
und ich kann hier nicht über das Buch sprechen,
sagen wir einfach danke,
dass Sie wissen, dass einigen Leuten
beigebracht wurde, dass das quietschende Rad das Fett bekommt,
ja, das ist eine Art Amerikaner, der Sie
ziemlich lautstark zu Wort kommt  Du wirst bekommen, was du
willst Viele Männer in Amerika wissen,
dass man
den Japanern beigebracht hat, dass der Nagel
, der herausragt, auf den Kopf getroffen wird
du kannst nicht sa
Irgendetwas Nettes sag überhaupt nichts
und den Chinesen wird beigebracht, die lauteste
Ente bekommt Tapas geschossen Gigzeit Ja,
aber alle sagen, sie wollen Vielfalt,
okay, also sagst du jetzt, okay, du hast deine
Vielfalt, du hast ein Rad, einen Kanal  ein
Nagel und ein nettes und wer macht all das
Reden am Rad, du weißt, und die
anderen reden, Oma hat ihnen beigebracht, nicht
laut zu sprechen, also brauchst du eine Organisation
, die erkennt, dass das meine Mission ist,
Urlaub, arrogante Erde, nein, das ist
wunderbar, und Booth, das ist mein Zuhause  Dies ist ein
Gefühlsfehler, Kind, auch dies ist, dass die Inés
zu feucht in tierischem Temperament sind, haben dies von
der Galatia-Opernparty in Bildnisnickel,
um auf ein Blatt in einer Genehmigung für die
Aussaat veränderter Sandbänke zu schließen
Sie haben unsere Zählung für das
diskriminierende Einkaufen gehalten. Oh, absolut,
ich meine, das nenne ich, Sie wissen, ich nenne das im
Grunde die Theorie der Arche Noah der
Vielfalt, die Gott ist,
wenn wir zwei von jedem in den Bogen bekommen
Haben Sie unsere Vielfalt, Sie wissen, tun Sie
dies, tun Sie dies, aber das
Problem ist, wenn die Giraffe
das Zebra im Bogen ansieht, sieht es nur
komisch aus
Sie wissen, wie Sie alles mit
diesem dummen kurzen Hals machen  Sie haben Recht,
damit nicht zwei von jeder Sache ausreichen.
Sie wissen, dass Sie Leute brauchen
, die die kulturellen
Unterschiede verstehen  sag ja okay
sag mir du weißt was die Briten
wirklich von den Franzosen halten du weißt
was die Inder wirklich von den
Pakistanis halten du weißt einer der Japaner
denkt wirklich von einem Chinesen was die
Australier wirklich von den Kiwis halten
Neuseeländer I  Ich weiß nicht, was es ist,
keine Schweiz, aber ich bin sicher, es gibt
etwas, ja, Sie wissen, und Sie
können all diese verschiedenen Leute haben, aber was
denken alle über alle, die Sie
kennen, Kanadier, da ist Kim Cam  pbells
Premierminister von Kanada, sie sagte einmal,
Sie wissen, denken Amerikaner, dass
Kanadier nur unbewaffnete Amerikaner mit
Krankenversicherung sind, aber bei uns um neun gekämpft haben, ein
paar Exemplare in Daphne erwarten
Angst vor Ihrer Führung als Frauen und
Team, und sie wollen daher einen Emu-Fiat  Die meisten
Sitze, da dies potenzielle Yucatan sind
, hatten wir nicht ausgestrahlt
Sprache, die du sprichst, ist etwas dominant, und
eines der Probleme ist, dass du weißt, welche
Sprache du sprichst, denn deine
Grundsprache ist, dass du sie kennst. Wenn ich nach Indien gehe,
merke ich oft, dass indische
Kollegen ihre Antworten wirklich lang,
wirklich lang sind, und ich habe einmal nach
Scizor gefragt  lang und er ist nur ich oh ja in der
schule
je länger die amps sind desto besser die
noten denn wenn ich mir die new
yorker manager ansehe die new yorker manager ja Mumbai
collie
sehr langsam M lon  g, weil die meisten Männer Alice
hören, dass der Größenmann immer noch cool zu
Helen war, ihm Tycoon Ken, das sind nicht
meine öko-glattsten, die offensichtlich sehen können, dass
deine Mutter ein strenges zu einem
bejahenden Wort vor dem Haus gibt,
ja ja ja, und aber das Problem ist  ist,
dass indische Dialekte jetzt als
Sprachen mit hohem Kontext bekannt sind. Sie sagen Ihnen
alles, was Sie im Zusammenhang
mit der Antwort wissen müssen. Amerikanisches Englisch war ein
Unterschied
die Kreaturen mit niedrigem Kontext und sie
gehen direkt aneinander vorbei, wissen Sie, und
die Sprecher mit niedrigem Kontext denken, dass die Sprecher mit hohem
Kontext dumm sind und sie
können die Frage nicht präzise beantworten und
sie wissen nicht, wovon sie reden,
und hoch  Kontextsprecher denken
den niedrigen Kontext, weil Sie wissen, dass sie
unhöflich sind. Sie wissen, dass es nicht der Unterschied
selbst ist, sondern wie wir den Unterschied wahrnehmen.
Wenn uns jemand nicht mag, werden
wir denken, oh, da ist es  Etwas
stimmt nicht mit ihnen, wissen Sie, ja, ja, bitten
Sie, unseren Namen zu hinterlassen, ja, und es ist so, dass
es ein Moment ist, Olivia,
besonders es tut mir leid, dass ich mich zurückziehe, und
Olivia kann in DB überlebt,
klingt wie Stalin, da wir uns darauf geeinigt haben, dass alles
Trump reingesteckt hat  air the one und so haben wir
nick v feely
viele unsere entscheidung ein gewaltiger schnitt
mit einem let's being stick
auffüllen anfang naina skin s kita frauen diese entwaffnen
das automatisch entlang der ski - richtig
und ich bin - schnurren - weiß ist der motor
hitori  und video blogging morgen die
früh auf vision und konsequenz auf gnade
mm oh ich war in indischer koch ein
tausendstel prozent die schwester natasha dann
quantifizieren obama system unsere lehrerin zeigt
und im gegensatz zu erhöhter diskriminierung ik
neutral ist
- elastance kampf für unsere haben genervt
so mendes  investiert in Industrieland auf Nischenessig
zurückziehen Spirituosen Chanson
Asthma jetzt sehen passieren von Alpha und E-
Glykan Karamell Fisch straffen die Wirtschaft
ADA's zuerst an Aaron Aaron behoove
out Subin  und wenn ich kann, bin ich echte
Burton Wissenschaft Loreen Bundesrat in
Beraterin und Präsidentin in ja ja,
also was auch immer für Minderheiten sind, nachdem er herausgefunden hat
, dass eine NT-Aktiengemeinschaften
weiter oben sind. Tut diese Hälfte meiner Mine, ist
heiß, Mann, Afrika tut mir auch weh
Gigs streamen laut für
sie, ja, ein paar Dinge, ich meine
, das ist ihre Meinung, natürlich, lass uns
in 20 Jahren mit ihr reden, mal sehen, was sie darüber denkt
, mm-hm, du weißt, nachdem sie
die Dinge ganz anders erlebt hat,
ja, du weißt, dass sie gerade schaut
und sagt  Ja, ja, Frauen sind in ihnen,
die an den Arbeitsplatz kommen usw., aber sie
hat vielleicht einige der Probleme nicht erlebt
, die sie letztendlich wahrscheinlich irgendwann treffen
werden, also weißt du, ja, es
gibt eine gewisse Gegenreaktion, ich verstehe, man
könnte sagen, dass eine Gegenreaktion ist  ein Hinweis darauf,
dass sich etwas ändert Sie wissen, dass Sie
ohne die Änderung keine Gegenreaktion bekommen
werden Sie wissen, dass Fortschritt keine
gerade Linie ist Sie wissen, dass es eine kleine
Schrittfunktion ist und Sie können gehen b  zurück
und dann gehst du weiter und weißt und
dann sagst du, du weißt, wer
betrübt ist, du weißt, wer seine
Macht verliert, weißt du, und ich denke, für viele
Männer und manche Frauen weißt du, dass der Status
quo das ist, was sie für richtig halten
Wissen Sie, eines der Dinge, die Sie meiner
Meinung nach wirklich bedrängen, sind die
Verschiebungen in den Geschlechterrollen, ja, und einige
Frauen wollen diese Verschiebungen nicht, viele
Männer wollen diese Verschiebungen nicht, also haben sie
eine Gegenreaktion darauf und so etwas  Sie
sagen, okay, warum ändern sich Menschen, wissen Sie
, denn das ist die ultimative Frage,
und Thukydides sagte, Menschen ändern sich aus
drei Gründen und drei Gründe haben nur
Angst vor Eigeninteresse oder Ehre, das ist ein
griechischer Begriff, also ist es eine Art Schmerzgewinn oder
Vision, für die es zu
vorsichtig ist  Ich soll mich nicht ändern Ich
verliere besser Gewicht, denn wissen Sie, wenn ich es nicht tue, was
werde ich gewinnen, wenn ich mich ändere, wissen Sie, oder habe
ich eine Vision davon, wohin die Welt
gehen
sollte?  wissen, dass manche Leute
das nicht wollen  Gehen Sie durch den Schmerz, den Sie
überhaupt damit kennen, also ist es
für mich nicht überraschend, dass wir einige
dieser Gegenreaktionen haben. Ich denke, Sie wissen, dass
die Leute mich oft gefragt haben, was Sie
tun müssen. Ich denke, wir machen Fortschritte und
ich bin  erinnerte an eine Anekdote, die John
Major, der ehemalige Premierminister des
Vereinigten Königreichs, erzählte, er habe Boris Jelzin angerufen, als
Jelzin an der Macht war, und er
sagte, Boris erzähle mir in einem Wort, wie es
in Russland läuft, und Jelzin antwortet
gut, er sagte gut  besser ausarbeiten
Boris erzähl mir in zwei Worten wie es
in Russland läuft in Jelzin antwortet nicht
gut du weißt schon als du mich gefragt hast wo wir
sind ich bin im guten nicht gut okay
irgendwann war ich Dienst - dann
Verschwinden es ist eine Vermutung ich zitiere auf wir
argumentierte auf dem ersten eAssist drehte sich darum,
wie es genug Projekt gut ist. Ich denke, es
hat einerseits die
Sichtbarkeit dessen erhöht, was das tägliche Leben von Frauen ist,
dass sie diese Art
von sexueller Belästigung oder
sie kennen diese Art von Diskriminierung durchmachen
Gegen sie machen sie das durch, was
passiert, wenn es ein übermäßiges Machtgefälle gibt,
ja, also denke ich, dass dies
die Sichtbarkeit enorm erhöht hat
, und einige der lautesten Verhaltensweisen, die ich verursache
, kennen Sie einige Männer, die nicht
auf ihnen sind, und daher ist es so, als ob
Sie es wirklich tun  So etwas würdest du
niemals tun, diesen
einen Schwindel, den du kennst, aber manche Männer
kennst du, besonders die in
wirklich hohen Machtpositionen, die glauben,
dass sie Leute dazu bringen können, das zu tun, was sie
wollen,
du würdest sie befreunden, also denke ich  Das hat
gut geklappt Ich denke, es gibt bis zu einem gewissen Grad eine Gegenreaktion. Die
Leute sind besorgt über
das, was er/sie gesagt hat,
und
folglich ist das keine dieser unbeabsichtigten
Folgen, die Sie wissen,
was in den Vereinigten Staaten die Mike-Pence-
Regel heißt  was auch immer wir sind,
Vizepräsident Pence sagt, er wird nie
mit uns in einem Raum sein, aber mit einer
Frau allein, er wird nie
mit einer Frau ohne seine Frau essen gehen,
und das ist der Punkt  Seine Männer
sagen jetzt: Oh, ich werde keine Frauen betreuen.
Ich werde ihn nicht zum Abendessen ausführen. Ich
werde nicht mit ihnen reisen. Das heißt, Sie
wissen, ich meine, das ist Newtons drittes Gesetz,
für jede Aktion gibt es ein Gleiches und ein
Gegenteil  Sie wissen, und das ist es,
was Sie mit dem sehen,
was potenziell sehr schädlich ist. Sie wissen, dass
ich den CEO kürzlich in dem von mir moderierten Panel gefragt habe,
was Sie tun würden, wenn einige
Männer Ihr Büro betreten würden, da Sie wissen, dass
ich gerecht bin  nicht Ich will nicht Ich will nicht
darauf eingehen Ich werde keine Frauen
zum Mittagessen einladen Ich werde nicht mit ihnen reisen
Ich werde sie nicht betreuen und Sie wissen,
der CEO hat gerade gesagt, wir müssen überwachen
Ihr eigenes Verhalten, Sie wissen, dass es um
Verhaltensfrauen geht, Sie müssen Ihr
eigenes Verhalten überwachen, und das wissen Sie, einige
Leute sagen einfach dazu, benimm dich einfach
anständig, ja, und das ist die Art des
grundlegenden philosophischen westlichen Babys,
anständig, aber ja, ich kann nicht widersprechen
Sie, aber ich glaube, es gab früher eine
Art Geschäft  Es ist ein Fall für Frauen,
was das Richtige war. Es sieht so aus, als würden
wir mit verschiedenen
Teams mit Frauen darin bessere Ergebnisse erzielen. Ich denke,
es geht um das Reputationsrisiko, Sie wissen,
dass es ihrem Image
schadet  Förderer sind so verwirrend, dass
TR Median als ein unglücklicher Honky-Tonk aus County
auf diesem sehr interessanten es sogar Klick
nach Ticket ist. Wer sonst noch als
Schwestern zählt,
es ist Feliciano und fünfzigtausend
irgendwelche Shows, es waren die Bemühungen,
diese erotische Carla-Bündelbefragung
der Materialität nach Hause zu beruhigen  Automatisiertes Auto II äh, war
es nicht
einfach, das wird auch ein bisschen knifflig,
weil Sie wissen, dass KI auf
Algorithmen basiert, und wenn 90%
der Algorithmen oder Männer Recht haben, dann sind wir wieder bei
einem bestimmten Weltbild, wie sie
denken  Weißt du, ich meine, ich denke, es waren
überall Facebooker, die ein Problem
mit den Algorithmen hatten, dass schwarze
Gesichter auftauchten. Du weißt genau,
dass das im Kopf von jemandem ist, den du kennst,
und es wurde eingebettet  o die
Algorithmen, also muss man bei
dieser Art von und Social Media ein wenig vorsichtig sein,
da wir wissen, dass es die gute, nicht
gute Art von Situation ist, die Sie kennen, weil
Frauen die ganze Zeit getrollt werden, Sie wissen
, dass sie belästigt werden  in den
sozialen Medien, wenn sie angeben, dass sie eine
feministische Position zu Dingen haben,
ja, Sie sehen es nur, ja, und
es ist Schweigen, und möglicherweise wissen
Sie, dass Sie wissen, wie der Oberste Gerichtshof
die Zwischenrufer nennt. Sie wissen, dass Sie
aufhören zu reden.  re
besorgt über den Zwischenrufer mr.  Medina ist
so gut, es sei denn, wir wissen, dass seine
Leidenschaft kommt, es passieren neue Kumpels in
jedem Teil der Episoden-CR-
Begrenzung und YouTube ist der gesättigte
Possen, es ist phänomenal,
es war eine Dose-Ergänzung zu Europa und
Jordan Petersons The Philomena,
besonders in der Nähe von Amandas Schnitt  Die
Hemden int und ihre Ähnlichkeit mit dem
Wissenschaftler über einen übermäßig
unterschiedlichen Mann und dominieren die Zerstörung
der Gesellschaft Ich werde weiterhin vor
Einkommen platzen, die ihre Liege wechseln,
ja, provokative arash-Einheiten und
andere Augen direkt unter verschiedenen Millionen
und lustigen Spaß erwähnen ihre eigenen Labors
noch angekündigt  weil sie es nicht besonders tut.
Ich meine, Sie können Pseudo-Fakten so ausrichten,
wie Sie wollen
Ja, mehr Männer starben,
bis vor etwa zwei Jahren Frauen
sogar im Kampf sein durften. Sie
wissen, dass diese Statistik so potenziell ist
wird irgendwann weggehen, also benutzt er
Dinge in einer sehr er hat
die Frau nicht sagen hören, die Hauptstadt und damit
Machtpositionen und all dieses
Zeug oder die Führer von Ländern, er
hat nichts davon gehört, weil  Das
ist nicht seine Weltanschauung oder
zumindest nicht seine Botschaft, die er zu vermitteln
versucht, und wenn Sie über unseren
Häusern stehen, fühlt sich die Polizei nicht emotional, also
sieht Philomena vielleicht Szenen, in denen sie dumm sind,
er ist es, der das bedient, was ich
denke  was ich als Verlust der
Zentralität bezeichnen würde, denn wenn Sie
Kräfte und nicht Dynamiken verschieben,
verlieren Sie möglicherweise Ihre Zentralität, die
Sie kennen, und andere teilen jetzt
diese Macht, und das ist nicht nur das Geschlecht
, das die Rasse ist, Sie wissen, dass die sexuelle
Orientierung ist, die Sie alle kennen  Dinge, die
es Ihnen ermöglichten, in diesem Sinne privilegiert zu sein, sollten
sich vielleicht gut entfernen, ja, und
schauen Sie
sich an  Diese Dinge
sagen, wer geschädigt wird, du weißt,
wer den Arbeitsplätzen in der Produktion schadet, geh
weg, wie wir Menschen
in neue Jobs umskalieren, damit du weniger provokative
Dinge kennst, die echte Lösungen sind
In den Vereinigten Staaten haben
wir etwas namens First
Amendment, das man ziemlich anders sagen kann,
als man es kennt. Wenn man in einem überfüllten Theater Feuer schreit,
bekommt er das Sprichwort, dass
er zweifellos diese Sichtbarkeit und
Aufmerksamkeit genießt, die auf ihn zukommen, und er
sieht sich an, dass jeder Führer eine Geschichte hat  zu erzählen
und dann hat ein anderer Anführer eine andere
Geschichte, richtig okay, und es ist so eine Art
Geschichte, die bei
den meisten Leuten ankommen wird, die
im Allgemeinen ausgewählt werden, oder so ähnlich, er
hat eine Nische von Leuten gefunden, die
mit dem, was er sagt, sie
bereits ansprechen  Da tun sie es und wir alle
tun es wir alle tun es
Bestätigungsverzerrung, weißt du, wenn ich so
etwas schon glaube und
dann kommt er daher und artikuliert es  Wovon ich
bereits glaube, dass du weißt, dass ich
alles ignorieren werde, was nicht bestätigt,
was ich glaube, und ich werde das
, wovon ich bereits glaube, überwältigend absorbieren
und jemand macht etwas wirklich
Dummes im Auto vor dir, der
fährt.
Fahrerin. Ich wusste es. Ich wusste es.
Du hast die fünf idiotischen Männer nicht gesehen, aber
du hast die eine idiotische Frau richtig gesehen
, also wirst du das haben
vorgefasste Meinung und dann versuchen Sie
herauszufinden, was Sie bereits glauben,
also ist er ein Experte. Das
jüngste Leichteste auf der Schuldenseite ist ein
pazifisches Land für Inselbewohner, das
lange mit
Polizisten zusammenstieß  bei jedem
duncan essen ist fisch Piyush floralis
würde dir danken wunderbares interview
danke
[musik]
du